I cannot tell you how entertaining you
both are in this film how much fun did
you have on set we enjoy this it because
it's you know somebody I'd like to
propose you to do something that
actually is non normal yeah
normally we are in general we like to
just get out of the box a little bit and
this was out of the box we got the
opportunity to to break when we called
it the fourth wall with the audience and
talked to them straight to the eyes from
our characters and at the same time
being the characters too so there is a
certain cynicism in everything that we
do in the movie that was interesting and
fun to play I can get over your matching
suits I couldn't pick a favorite you got
it just added so much to the smarmy Ness
of your characters yeah I had not seen I
had not really seen all the costumes
that Antonia was wearing and he had not
seen everything I had picked or was
picked you know by a young Ellen yeah
and so we at one point at the studio we
had these little bungalows dressing
rooms next to one another they were like
little that white picket fences in
Alabama houses so course we'd go in and
change and then come out and I each
other up going like that tie so we were
it was it was a lot of it's a lot of fun
you don't often get to well first of all
we met and we we met and we got on I cut
this would be a nightmare if you were
partnered with someone yeah that you
just that you just didn't like and that
you had to fake chemistry but we but we
got on so we it was you know it was a
joy to come in every day well I know
obviously Panama papers is a very
serious topic but what I loved about
your characters is that we're not
supposed to like you but there's a charm
quality there and it's just an
interesting way of seeing
your characters perspective as to what
went down so why do you think the
comedic elements worked so well telling
a story about something really quite
serious well I think that was the the
the big thing about the script that I
certainly responded to it was taking
something that was quite into at times
certainly with Ellen Merrill's character
you know that's that's it's a pretty
dark story there am but the but the
medicine is sweetened with with the
absurd heightened kind of reality of it
and then the humor of it so that was
what I think originally what made I
responded to the script because our
characters were like ring-ring-ring
masters or gameshow hosts you know and
also we had the chance to it's a little
bit like a confession mm-hmm we have the
opportunity to tell the audience hey you
know what yeah this may have gone down
but if you think we're bad then check
out these people over here so it was it
was so nice it's a delivery system to
the to the you know to the audience it's
it's it's heightened comedic irony is
it's a you know it's almost like a
problem nation of humor and a
prolongation of intelligence in a
certain way and I think a we are very
intelligent director behind the whole
project and but you have to present it
like that it's not a it's not a funny
movie because we are doing gags in front
of the camera or anything
I think people laugh of how our rages
the situations are and how far you know
this thing goes this thing that is very
difficult to actually understand I mean
the artifact of taxation or all around
the world the lowest implicated in these
the
people the amount of people thousands of
people you know behind all of these made
it so complicated that you laugh of it
because at the end you know as I said
something in the church and just they
came like you know when I was watching
the movie again this is called tax
avoidance and tax avoidance is legal
everything that these guys were doing
it's legal that is what is joke of
course in engulfed in the Panama papers
there are different levels and there
there is a level of really criminals
that were using this you know artifact
that I was describing before to laundry
money and there you can count with
people that is in drugs trafficking with
drugs or a weapon so even humans
probably terrorism but then there are
people that they have companies there
they there are you know legit people
people that don't know that they look
for an adviser an adviser may have just
asked them a question that is viewers to
anybody it will answer probably in the
same way and the question is do you
wanna pay more or less taxes and people
may say less I said but I want to be
legal don't worry you know that is a way
to do this fight yeah do you do your own
accounting no right so you put a lot of
faith in someone's judgment you know
because if they come knocking at the
door they're not gonna they're gonna
come for you yeah I'm not going to come
for the person I was doing your taxes
they're gonna come for you because you
should have it's assumed that you should
be or knowing about it about these
things and just working a year in May
working for five countries it may happen
you know with different taxations
I have no idea how to solve this problem
the end of the year so I have to hire
some money and again is what he said you
trust just put all your confident that
person is you know defending your name
basically doing things legally but if
he's not for whatever reason he's out of
the game and you were maybe in front of
a judge being accused of something that
you basically don't understand what is
the message that you hope the audience
takes away from this film is there a
lesson in here or just you want people
to really understand what happened
probably to look to the micro world you
know to be alert of what do you do
maybe that's the main thing and the
second big thing is put attention in
political campaigns what they propose
you in taxes you know what is the
proposal from the government and what
you can demand from them to a certain
degree yeah I think that you know once
you should be able to just do it all it
should be just be two pages long you
know the US tax code is I see 6,000
pages okay I mean it's so much you know
it's designed to make you a criminal but
you know what I mean I mean you've got a
you know the average person you should
be able to do it two forms tick the box
and sign and so it's my and it's
deliberately made that way
it's like lawyers isn't it how they used
to how they used to be paid they you
know they used to be paid by the word
I didn't know that yeah you know the
language lawyers language aforementioned
underscored the you know all it's so
it's over Bose it's because they were
paid by the word oh my god I was so you
get as many words in there as you can
yeah yeah I mean that's why this is this
is so far back that's why Shakespeare
said you know first we kill the lawyers
they were doing it they were doing it
back yeah
so can we possibly see you two in
another film again because I didn't know
they needed you two together in another
film I loved your chemistry well they've
already done Laurel and Hardy and we are
way more handsome than those guys we are
we are both amazing congratulations on
the film was very nice to meet you guys
you